as a newscaster it just breaks my heart
to see boarded up shops
unfinished buildings they were
somebody's dream
i remember before the boom before the
bust
i said this is a town where anyone can
make it i still believe
if you watch eyewitness news you'll see
you'll see what's what's going on right
now someplace where there's news and
that's you know i think that's a
wonderful way for people to get closer
well we talked a little while ago we
showed you the top 19 stories in las
vegas during the year 1999 and asked you
if you had figured out what number one
was what the 20th was have you
well time to find out
the one we missed that you and i missed
was the hacienda that's right it was on
new year's eve and we were live at uh
treasure island treasure island for a
new year's eve program and to get down
the strip to austin had come back so we
wound up watching that one on television
but we've seen the rest of them live and
it's always quite an experience
one week from today a federal appeals
court in san francisco will hear
arguments on two nevada cases cases tied
to the area 51 military base some say
it's the pentagon it's on trial others
say it's the constitution itself the
early morning darkness when the las
vegas strip was almost deserted howard
hughes arrived in las vegas and was
spirited away to the top floor of the
desert inn hotel he was supposed to stay
ten days he stayed four years to the day
and during those four years bought
practically everything he could get his
hands on including klas tv more than 20
million americans say they have seen an
unidentified flying object yet the
subject of ufos is generally scorned by
science journalism and the government an
eyewitness news investigation into the
topic that was broadcast last november
has drawn worldwide attention slot
machines and gambling devices are
virtually synonymous with las vegas
they're everywhere grocery stores
laundromats the airport of course in
bars
for millions
[Music]
going live to the hilton hotel but the
latest reports are that the fire is out
there's still a lot of smoke in the
hotel that was then
this is now
then
now
then
now
now
8 news now politics is one thing nevada
politics is something else you have to
know the key players their history what
they stand for and what they stood for
in the past
our reporters have been covering nevada
politics for decades that's experience
earned over time experience you rely on
to make wise choices the survival of our
state is at stake on impact nevada we're
cutting through the political noise to
get to the heart of nevada's challenges
this city is a survivor and the hard
workers here need reliable information
i like to think that just doing my job
well is helping it bounce back my name
is gary waddell and las vegas is my home
you